the ring sword of a vowel is seen all
throughout the trailer what if this is
Gertrude the missing heavenly daughter
the batwing demons always were a lesser
chaos demon and the old words of the
pilgrims continue to come true there is
a lot to answer for and already a lot to
see in the Ring City the Ring City is
said to be at World's End past this heap
of rubbish as far as one can go so when
I'm showing these still images on the
screen I'm actually quoting the
promotional images and the descriptions
which came with them which a lot of you
who view the trailer might have missed
this is called the Drake heap the
farthest end of the world and just as we
thought this conglomerate of cities
represents Dark Souls threes core theme
of converging worlds with and they quote
various remains from different
historical periods accumulating here
over time and beyond as the narrator
says is the Ring City and the ancient
ruin half covered in foliage and likely
fallen to the abyss as locusts have
arisen here feasting on anything and
everything that is in their path and
curiously in the notes that I've been
provided it is also called the
traditional city of the pygmies are they
talking about the descendants of the
furtive pygmy perhaps humanity that's an
amazing detail but regardless of that
I'm already tempted to call this place
Lundell the home of the pilgrims also
because hidden upon the architecture on
at least three roofs and in the rubble
here you can clearly see this design
that is identical to the ringed sword of
a vowel which is that ceremonial blade
of Londo that yuria gives us to
sacrifice
unruhe with which is this act that
cements us as the lord of Hallows and
given that this sword is everywhere here
I expect that this act will be
elucidated in the DLC explaining its
nature a little bit more which is a
really welcome detail
so to brush up on mando and what this
means you should watch this video by the
way and I think that video is really
important now because what the pilgrims
have said seems to be holding a lot of
weight as they've accurately predicted
the close of the age of fire and finally
in this DLC it looks like we're seeing
what comes beyond the age of fire and
that we're going to be helping to
dictate what comes next which begs the
question where will we enter this DLC
and I actually think it's possible that
we'll access it at the end of the game
so long as you choose one of the endings
that you serve the flame or allows it to
die because think about it from software
does like putting the entrance to the
dlc towards the start somewhere like
arendelle
however this is the one time they could
get away with putting the DLC at the
very end of the base game because this
might well be the last addition to the
Dark Souls series and obviously these
environments were being shown are really
really suited to the kiln of the first
flame or if not there then at least
somewhere in Upper lauric which you can
only access after the dark Sun has risen
in the sky and the dark Sun is all
throughout this trailer and lothric does
play a part in this DLC also in the
trailer we see lothric Knights bearing
this banner and I looked for this duel
dragon crested banner it's off to the
left of this bridge in the dragon
barracks additionally this crest is seen
on the tab odds of the winged Knights
which relates to Gertrude which we'll
get to in a minute
so the more the rounded rooftops in
these shots they're similar to the
rounded rooftops of the grand archives
and in fact we see the very bookcases of
the grand archives in the background of
this scene as this thin creature with a
show tell crawls towards the main
character in the foreground who wield
the short sword that activates into a
kind of crystal magic lightsaber
and the grand archives is a significant
reference here because that is where
Gertrude one of the Queen's heavenly
children was imprisoned and her identity
is a major mystery that we discussed in
depth over here in this video so why am
i bringing up Gertrude well bear with me
another one of the heavenly children was
Rosario mother of rebirth and this woman
in the trailer looks awfully like her
from the larger body to the dark
straight hair to the fair skin she could
well be a sibling to Rosario and that's
why I think she could well be Gertrude
the missing heavenly daughter Gertrude
was said to have been visited by an
angel who revealed a tale to her that
became the foundation of the angelic
face of lothric however the worship of
this became heresy which led to go
through to being imprisoned in the grand
archives but when we come across this
cell Gertrude was nowhere to be found
and the cell itself was surrounded by
winged ascended Knights
Gertrude also was said to be blind and
there is a darkness encroaching upon
this woman's eyes the circlet is also a
symbol of royalty and the white clothing
is easily associated with the angelic
faith so I think it is possible that
this is Gertrude possible that's all
I'll say on that let's move on to the
egg that she rests upon eggs in Dark
Souls 2 was said to symbolize the
deepest secrets of existence and it was
also where we found the petrified egg
right before we found an ancient dragon
and there are screenshots that show that
arch dragons are part of this DLC as
well first a shield formed by the head
of a descendant of an arch dragon and
second a gray giant who has existed
since the arch dragon was found this
giant it is said used to be adjudicator
working under the gods a judge
I wonder what he
his judgment on was the arch dragon
found within the egg perhaps at first I
thought that the creature birthed from
this egg might have been this fire demon
since it was shown immediately after but
after a little bit of research I'm
confident I know exactly what this chaos
demon is its skull and its body is
identical to those of the batwing demons
seen in Dark Souls 1 and 3 there are
great connections here
so the batwing demons have long been
theorized to be messengers of the gods
they take you to and from an Orlando
city of the gods in Dark Souls 1 and
they take you down to the undead
settlement from lothric as escorts in
Dark Soul 3 but make no mistake these
things are and always have been chaos
demons the ones we've just seen so far
they're just the lesser form of them the
demons fear from Dark Souls 1 reads
carved from the bones of fellow demons
wielded by the slim lesser batwing
demons and the bat wings they aren't the
only example of demons serving royalty
by the way take the asylum demons for
example which serve as gatekeepers in
lothric and guards in Dark Souls 1 so
this I'm sure is a greater batwing demon
as opposed to the lesser ones and as the
screenshots say it's the last survivor
of demons who were born from the flame
of chaos dwelling below the land it
sports a grotesque look from being
exposed to poison and its flame is
fading away health is even unused
content for a great bats soul belonging
to one that was sealed below the earth
so even though the last living witness
of lost izalith is dead the creations of
chaos continue to live below the earth
in a DLC that is increasingly looking
like the primordial place that the
entire series sprouted from it has the
last demons of the old witches chaos it
apparently has the pygmies first home
it has the pilgrims of Lundell it has
the first descendants of dragons and the
new home to the abyss and even Gale and
Arya are at the end of the trailer so
how much more can they cram into this
place I've heard rumors that this DLC is
going to be larger than the previous
ones and they sure are setting us up for
a lot I almost doubt that they can live
up to talking about all these things in
good detail but to finish this video I
know it's a bit roundly I put it
together in one night I'm going to throw
some tidbits at you now that I couldn't
work into the main narrative of this
video so more screenshots
this is wrap self-proclaimed amnesiac
Hollow with heavy plate armor who you
will encounter in the drag heap the
conglomeration of kingdoms you see here
this is described as a vicious night
sunken in a swamp and instead of a head
the Columbus darkness swells I want to
point out that the lothric Knights have
roots growing over them as if they
haven't moved in quite some time and I
want to say that those sexy Pyromancer
women of Dark Souls 2 they're coming
back I think the screen shot description
strongly suggests that they'll be making
a reappearance I forgot to mention the
character wielding a bow that clearly
has a lightning arrow webinar and
finally like a butterfly emerging from a
cocoon this undead bursts forth in a
flash of light it looks so much like the
pilgrim butterflies right the tendrils
at the lower half are almost identical
to the pilgrim butterfly tendrils and
the wings kind of have similar veins
through them and the way his spine
arches backwards remind me of those
butterflies although the head is
undeniably different or maybe it's a
kind of angel anyway let me know what
you think of the DLC I'll be rolling out
my notes that I wrote about the trailer
so far to the beacon to a patron so you
guys in that tier you can look forward
to that but thank you for watching
special
if your subscriber as well and now after
10 hours of writing and editing and
narrating I'm going to go to bed I'll
see you soon
[Music]